il est présenté comme le des plus beaux
sites de l'île l'un des plus beaux
domaines en tout cas qui présente un
fort potentiel
le domaine de la pagerie aux trois ilets
bonjour manuel à yongning bonjour vous
êtes la directrice du site qui regroupe
trois espaces on le rappelle le musée de
la pagerie le parc à des floralies et la
maison du docteur robert rose rose est
un domaine qui a pu être revisités à
l'occasion des récentes journées du
patrimoine avec l'exposition rose est
oui en effet le domaine de la pagerie à
nous avons rendu hommage au dr oz vous
êtes le fondateur du musée
dans le droit fil du projet de
développement de la pagerie en 2015
devrait rappeler que ce domaine a été
repris par la collectivité publique
puisqu'il était en gestion par une
association est très tôt depuis 2015
nous nous interrogions avec des
chercheurs des universitaires des
historiens sur l'histoire d'avenir que
nous allions proposé aux martiniquais et
nous étions accordés sur le fait qu'il
nous fallait
revisiter l'oeuvre du fondateur du musée
qui à l'époque avait réussi à drainer 70
mille touristes pour comprendre un peu
son oeuvre pour la partager la mettre en
débat en s'appuyant sur quoi exactement
avec l'oeuvre de la traverse est heureux
du docteur robert aux roses est ce en
s'appuyant sur la stratégie des publics
qu'il avait mise en oeuvre nous avons
beaucoup étudié avec l'aide de
l'association aubert rosette passion
martinique présidée par françoise rosay
tu es avec les émissions canopée la
stratégie mise en oeuvre qui était très
tôt dès le début par le docteur aux
roses est une stratégie ou joséphine et
elle accroche pour présenter la
martinique au monde
cela veut dire que il y avait très tôt
une stratégie vers l'international
cela ne veut pas dire que le domaine de
la pagerie qui aujourd'hui appartient la
ctm il faut le souligner s'oriente vers
cette orientation mais en tout cas nous
revisitons cette oeuvre pour la
présenter aux martiniquais pour
l'analyser pour en débattre et peut-être
pour enrichir la vision du domaine de la
page vous avez parlé de canopée c'est à
dire que l'éducation nationale et tout
ce qui est éducatif sera concernée par
ce projet absolument
l'exposition qui est visitable et à
laquelle j'invite l'ensemble des
martiniquais jusqu'en juin 2019 est
assortie d'un cahier pédagogique
l'attention des enseignants et des
scolaires qui permet aux enseignants de
préparer la visite en amont pendant et
après c'est un cahier pédagogique qui
s'adresse aux cycles deux cycles 3 6 que
si que le 4 donc nous avons intégré
cette cible alors manuel à yongning on a
beaucoup parlé de ce site un qu'on
trouve un petit peu à l'abandon il y
avait eu beaucoup de projets on rappelle
que vous êtes en place depuis mai 2015
si je ne me trompe
alors quels sont les enjeux pour ce site
répartie sur trois trois espaces bien
défini alors on en a beaucoup parlé
sûrement parce que ce site pendant
longtemps n'était pas encore dans la
collectivité publique
je voudrais rappeler que ce site a été
repris en 2015 moi je suis arrivé
voulait souligner en mai 2015 par l'ex
conseil général et l'objectif était d'en
définir une vision puisqu'il ne
s'agissait plus du musée de la pagerie
de manière très restrictive mais de
trois espaces vous l'avez souligné une
vision de développement a été très
rapidement mises en place et validées
qui est aujourd'hui aux mains de la ctm
du président et notamment du conseiller
exécutif en charge de la culture des
axes de développement avait été posée
c'est un chantier titanesque trois sites
cependant sur ce grand projet de
développement pour répondre à votre
question trois axes ont déjà été menées
l'acce de la conception et de la
définition d'une offre d'activités
culturelles la pagerie a mis en place un
programme assez innovant d'activités qui
sont les siennes en de l'aude au delà
des temps en récurrent des journées du
patrimoine et cetera nous avons croisé
les politiques publiques nous organisons
par exemple une course patrimoniales
culturelles et sportives en liant ces
deux politiques publiques une nuit du
conte le vin me où nous travaillons avec
des historiens du compte des compteurs
sur l'histoire de ce domaine nous avons
aussi défini déjà un début d'une
stratégie de recherche la page et doit
être selon nous un lieu de production de
savoirs et aujourd'hui nous travaillons
avec l'université les étudiants
d'ailleurs ce week-end nous accueillons
les journées d'intégration des étudiants
de l'année
sens de guides conférenciers nous avons
aussi travaillé à quelque chose
d'important
la sécurisation des personnes et des
biens des réseaux électriques ont été
refaits des bâtiments maintenu c'est un
début mais nous semble être le pendant
trois ans depuis trois ans tout l'aspect
historique sera remise en valeur même si
le personnage de joséphine demeure
personnage décrit en bas par heure on
veut pas refaire l'histoire mais vous
reparler de point d'ancrage
d'accrochages à travers joséphine est ce
que les martiniquais sont prêts à ça
alors j'ai parlé de la proche du docteur
rose rose est d'accord par joséphine la
proche qui est en débat à la septème
aujourd'hui qui est porté par le
président et marie-hélène août un c'est
de dire que quand vous arrivez à la
pagerie vous ne voyez pas joséphine vous
voyez avant tout un patrimoine bâti des
items d'une ancienne habitation une
sucrerie
il faut revaloriser tout ça il faut
remettre tous en avons alors nous nous
sommes en train de travailler à jean
veut dire une mémoire intégrale -non pas
sélective nous proposons là nous sommes
en train de travailler au programme de
2019 et nous proposons par exemple la
mort d'un chantier de fouilles sur
l'habitat servile parce que si nous
partons du postulat de ce patrimoine
bâti d'une ancienne habitation sucrière
ça veut dire qu'il y a eu une main
d'oeuvre donc il y a eu des esclaves et
qu'il convient peut-être d'enrichir le
discours par une production de savoirs
et un chantier de fouilles
archéologiques
ce que je veux dire par là il nous
semble important de ne pas opposer les
deux discours celui de joséphine et
celui de l'esclavagé dont existé mais de
travailler justement à cette politique
des publics
que voulons nous raconter à la pagerie
que voulons nous léguer à nos enfants
qu'est ce que nous voulons qu'ils
retiennent et au delà de ça à quel
public nous adressons nous alors
l'international que les touristes quels
lots ligne puisque je crois comprendre
que vous avez des contacts très très
fort avec des pays comme les etats-unis
comme le japon
ça peut marcher ça absolument et ça
marche ça marche c'est à dire que quand
nous sommes arrivés à la pagerie nous
avons structuré
j'ai envie de dire une relation de
confiance avec les acteurs touristiques
que sont les agences de voyages de la
martinique est d'ailleurs on en a même
une des états unis
qui vendent le produit pagerie cela veut
dire qu'il ya une réelle confiance qui
est établi et qui a une demande
nos chiffres ont été très bons cette
année mais bon il participe dans le
contexte global et les demandes dont
vous parliez nous ne sommes même pas
aller les chercher le danemark le pays
du bonheur par exemple nous sollicitent
pour que se tienne un congrès des
scientifiques autour de l' esclavage
c'est un signe ils ont acheté la pagerie
le japon récemment nous les avons reçus
pour un reportage qui va passer une télé
japonaise les états unis ce sont nos
clients de tout temps j'ai envie de dire
cela veut dire que la pagerie est
présente dans le monde
maintenant c'est un axe mais il me
semble que la pagerie doit aussi être le
lieu de tous les martiniquais tout à
dire que vous avez écrit des ateliers
comme on l'a vu pendant les grandes
vacances pour apprendre à confectionner
autour de la de la calebasse auprès
faire toutes sortes de choses y compris
y compris de nouvelles activités pour
faire venir les martiniquais alors nos
chiffres nous montrent que la
fréquentation des martiniquais est en
progression
vous parliez tout à l'heure du docteur
aux roses est au delà de l'exposition
dimanche nous avons expérimenté un conte
qui racontait l'histoire du docteur aux
roses est où des jeunes de 18 ans est
intégré à ce compte beaucoup de
martiniquais était là et empreint
d'émotion ils nous ont même remercié de
leur permettre de revenir sur ce domaine
sur des choses qui les conserve un
patrimoine martiniquais le docteur
rosette et j'ai envie de vous dire que
oui nous nous travaillons sur les les
deux cibles exemple au moins d'octobre
nous travaillons à un public qui souvent
exclues de la culture vous savez ces
femmes qui luttent pour être en vie qui
sont atteintes de cancer le dimanche 28
nous leur ouvrons les portes de la
pagerie et nous créons des rencontres
solidaires de la pagerie ou ce public
viendra pour des activités culturelles
avec les jardins font du bien on entend
beaucoup ça l'ambition de la pagerie ci
d'être une maison commune amusé citoyens
qui est dans l'inclusion et non pas dans
l'exclusion l'un ne va pas gêner l'autre
parlons du parc des floralies pour
tellement dit ah oui c'est un site
extraordinaire qui étaient délaissées
complètement abandonnés ou concernant ce
parc floral alors le pape des floralies
a été
j'ai envie de dire un peu restauré avant
mon arrivée en 2015
il est en état il reste quelques travaux
à finaliser la septème est en train de
les évaluer
mais la 7e n'est pas resté les bras
croisés pour donner des signes forts
d'ouverture au public
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que s'est
tenu le premier martinique jazz festival
en 2015
aujourd'hui biguine jazz c'est une
réflexion qui est en gestation parce que
le parc des floralies doit répondre à
une vision globale
c'est un site qui représente plusieurs
trames la trame spectacle vivant
culturel mais la trame verte
c'est un espace où la la la botanique la
biodiversité
la trame sportive je pense que c'est
réellement une vision qui est posée
qu'il convienne enrichir de traduire
financièrement et de partager merci
d'avoir été ce matin avec nos manuels à
yongning en rappel vous êtes la
directrice du domaine de la pagerie
trois ilets bonne journée